المحليات الصناعيه التي نلجا اليها عاده
كبديل السكر يبدو انها اخطر منه فدراسه
طبيه حديثه توصلت لانه يمكن ان تزيد من
خطر الاصابه بالنوبات القلبيه والسكتات
الدماغيه نتائج الدراسه التي نشرت بدوريه
من المحليات المضافه الى الاطعمه المصنعه
قد تزيد من خطر الاصابه بجلطات الدم وجد
الباحثون للاشخاص الذين لديهم في دمائهم
كميات كبيره من الاثريتول هو سكر صناعي
ويستخدم كمحلل صناعي في اكثر من 50 دوله
كانوا اكثر عرضه للاصابه بنوبه قلبيه او
سكته دماغيه بمقدار الضعف مقارنه بمن كانت
لديهم كميات اقل
المحليات الصناعيه تحولت الى عنصر ثابت
فيما نتناوله يوميا من طعام وشراب ومن
حبوب وزبادي وقهوه سريعه التحضير كما تدخل
في صناعه العقاقير مثل المضادات الحيويه
هذه المحليات يتم بيعها باعتبارها بدائل
صحيه منخفضه السعرات للسكر الذي يسبب
زياده الوزن وتسوس الاسنان لكن دراسات
علميه عديده تثير تساؤلات حول سلامه هذه
المحليات الصناعيه منظمه الصحه العالميه
وضعت ارشادات تنص على ضروره عدم استخدام
المحليات الصناعيه لغرض السيطره على الوزن
توفر هذه المحليات المذاقه الحلو للسكر
لكن عاده ما يكون اقل من السكر من ناحيه
السعرات الحراريه تكون هذه المحليات ايضا
عاده اقل تكلفه من السكر لان مده صلاحيتها
اطول اي طويله الامد مع كثافه عاليه من
التح ليه هذا يسمح لبدائل المحليات ان
تستعمل في المنتجات التي لن تنتهي
صلاحيتها بعد فتره قصيره من الزمن
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا في الاستوديو دكتوره وفاء حلمي
استشاريه التغذيه علاجيه دكتوره يسعد
صباحك صباح الورد صباح الفل والياسمين
اهلا وسهلا المحليات الصناعيه تزيد مخاطر
الاصابه بالسكته الدماغيه ونوبات القلب
الى الايمن هذا دقيق اوكي هلا بدنا حسب
الدراسه انه بدايه بدنا نحتاج لدراسات
اخرى حتى يتم هي دراسه او دراستين تمت على
بعض الاشخاص اللي تناولوا المحليات بشكل
يومي بكميات تتجاوز المسموح به وهذا وهم
اصلا عندهم مشاكل خلينا نقول مبدئيا واحد
اي اي محليات بناخذها زياده عن الحد تتحول
الى دهون تؤثر الى سلبا على صحه الجسم وقد
تؤدي الى انسداد الشرايين فيما بعد هاي
واحد اثنين كل المحليات عشان نكون لسا كان
في انه انه ايش بدنا ناكل كل المحليات
فيما اذا استهلكت بالكميات المعقوله
والمدروسه حسب
يعني انه ما تزيد عن الحد لانه كل شيء
يزيد عن الحق ينقلب للضد وبالتالي اذا انا
اخذتها في ضمن اطار المعقول وهذا المعقول
كيف انت بدك تنتبهي انها وين موجوده
موجوده في موجوده في المخبوزات موجوده في
الموجوده في الفيتامين بعض الفيتامينات
على فكره موجوده في كثير من
الاغذيه اللي بتنعمل على اساس تكون
لوكالوري او يعني دكتوره وفاء بهاي الحاله
لما نقول مثلا عن شغله شوجر فري هاي صارت
كذبه كبيره لا لا ابدا ابدا هلا
في بعض
كثير عم ينخموا
ممكن يكون فيها فات فانت بدك تقرئي
الحيره فيما عشان هيك انا بشكركم لانه
وجودي معكم وضح هاي النقطه على الاقل
الناس حتصير تقرا انه
شقر يعني ما فيها سكر ما فيها دهون ولكن
الاساس في لما انا بطلع على المحليات وهذا
اللي بدي اللي بشكركم لاضاءه عشان عم
بتحطوا الضوء على هذا الموضوع كثير من
الناس بيروحوا للاشياء اللي فيها محليات
او شقر او مضاف اليه شكر وبياخدوا كميات
كثير كبيره اولا بتسبب اسهال قد تؤثر
لتليف في الكبد قد تؤدي الى مواد اخرى على
الرغم خليني اقول معلومه كثير واضحه عشان
بس ما يكون سوء فهم كل المحليات امنه
استخدامها اذا تم استخدامها في حدود
المعقول شو الكميه المسموحه
اولا على حسب في حسب النوع يعني مثلا
خلينا نقول في انواع بتعطيكي اربع كالوريس
وبالتالي تحسب على حسب سعرات الحراريه
بحيث انها ما تزيد وفي السفر سعرات حراريه
ولكن المسموح فيها اذا زاد يعني مثلا
خلينا نقول نفس الارستو اللي محطوط في هو
سكر هو كربوهيدرات ومن سكريات الكحوليه
اللي موجوده
لكل كيلو جرام بالوزن وان غرام فعلى حسب
وزن اذا زاد عن ذلك
يتخزن على هاي الدهون يؤدي الى مشاكل اخرى
وبالتالي ايضا خليني اقول معلومه معظم
المحليات بتدخل على الجسم ما بيتم هضمها
ولا امتصاصها بتروح على القولون على طول
تتخمر في القولون وبالتالي
نفخه
انتفاخ القولون غازات اسهال لها علاقه
بالماده اللي
قرانا عنها
بتسبب قلق وخرف المستقبل هو نوع من انواع
المحليات على فكره
وكان لفتره كان عليه كتير قصص ولكن الاف
دي
ايز انه امن
اذا تم تناوله
بالكميات اللي لازمه حتى تنفيذ المشاهدين
اول شيء خليني احكي معلومه انه الكالوري
اذا كان سعر الحراريه كان في دراسه جديده
انعملت فيه كندا تمت الان بمؤتمر القلبيه
من اسبوعين تقريبا وتم نشر دراسه الف شخص
انه اذا السعر الحريه يجب ان تحسب
وبالتالي هي تدخل الجسم
وكيفيه حرقها هو هو المفيد اذا انا اكون
نشيط اتناول معدل السعرات الحراريه حسب
البيزل تبعي حسب معدل الايض وبالتالي انا
بطمن اني انا ما بصير عندي مشاكل هاي واحد
اثنين اقرا اذا شو قالت لي هل هو فات فري
وهذا اللي حضرتك تفضلتي فيه اول شيء انه
بس مين قال انه ما في فاتوره ايضا بيزيد
الوزن وبالتالي ممكن يتخزن اذا في كثير
مشاكل انا في غنى عنها كل المحليات يجب ان
اخذها المراه مسموح لها خلينا نقول بحدود
40 غرام والرجل 45 غرام يعني بحدود 19
معلقه تقريبا اوكي واحنا كتير بنشكرك على
كل هذه المعلومات دكتوره وفاء حلب
استشاريه التغذيه علاجيه شكرا